[Musica]
c'era un pozzo non sembrava
importante era costruito camion evanka
brutalmente martirizzato un adulto poteva lasciare che
potesse guardarci sopra e anche un
bambino con climi come tutte le parole
era ambiguo bifronte che era
dentro e cosa c'era  fuori dipendeva
da che parte eri da quanto
sono grandi gli occhi di un bambino la migrazione è
un fenomeno scivoloso petizioni è molto
difficile misurare la popolazione ed è
più difficile contare quante persone vivono nel
paese che stava arrivando nel 2015
c'erano circa 21 milioni di immigrati che
vivevano nell'Unione Europea da
paesi terzi e io sono uno dei circa 900.000
ucraini che vivono nell'UE L'Ucraina è
il gradino dell'Europa ed è vicino
alla porta dell'Unione Europea Gli ucraini hanno
vinto l'UE e  la parte migliore di loro che
risiede sopra il paese che risiede
che in Polonia Italia Germania Spagna e
Repubblica Ceca l'Ucraina ha voluto così tanto
che molti di loro vivono ogni giorno i
passaporti ai trafficanti di esseri umani e  Non sto
parlando del milione di X e dei
600.000 sfollati interni, il luogo in cui le
persone che vivono oggi come
rifugiati nel paese a causa
della crisi del jumba ognuno di voi ha un
passaporto probabilmente perso in un cassetto o un
samaritano un opuscolo con
Harkavy di colore diverso e la specie
di emblema del tuo paese scherzando uomo non
tanto come fa Brecht scrive che un
uomo può nascere per caso ma non il
passaporto è la parte più nobile
di noi e oggigiorno non abbiamo valore come
persone senza è divertente ma  quando
siamo bambini piccoli le istruzioni
ci consigliano di non giocare con i sacchetti di plastica
per tenerci al sicuro
quando invece siamo grandi le istruzioni
ci consigliano di non giocare con il nostro passaporto
per tenerlo al sicuro
passaporti identicard I
numeri di previdenza sociale sono molto importanti per la nostra
burocrazia  un documento contiene molte
informazioni utili sulla nostra ad
esempio il nostro nome la data e il luogo di
nascita sesso il sesso e il luogo in cui
viviamo e molte altre informazioni che
qualche nazione richiede o ha richiesto il
passato ad esempio il nome dei nostri genitori il
nostro lavoro e anche la nostra religione e
infine un documento deve avere un numero
che è il nostro numero ad esempio secondo
il mio passaporto i miei numeri pa zero nove
tre sette otto nove ok ma  non riesco a
capire dove sto meglio nel mio
passaporto non ci sono informazioni utili
su di me come documento personale risulta
tutta la mia identità cioè tutta la
mia storia il mio passaporto sono una combinazione di
dettagli che messi insieme non avevano
senso  se vuoi davvero conoscermi akia
party enna questo è il test di ammissione a
spirulina il luogo dove abito nel
sud Italia vicino a napoli vicino al mare
vicino alle montagne e e lontano da
tutto se hai una contessa
padonia qualcuno probabilmente un vecchio  Romano
a chi stai chiedendo indicazioni
potrei chiederti alla tua festa ana cosa
significa che ci vivo da
13 anni e ancora non so
esattamente cosa significhi che
ho tenuto Athena è qualcosa  g come a
chi appartieni e anche per i tuoi genitori
che hanno a che fare con quale è il tuo
quartiere dove vivi e
meglio a chi posso chiedere
di te una serie di domande personali e
complicate non pensi che
questa vecchietta non sia una  agente di pattuglia di frontiera
con cappelli una pistola e un bottone
ha solo qualche ruga occhi rossi una
voce adorabile e il bastone da passeggio
immaginarti in un tachimetro su di loro è una
giornata di sole una vista di te è nella visuale
sulla strada passando per i carburanti  case
e una chiesetta e la faccia sorridente
ti sta chiedendo tutta la tua storia quindi
hai il passaporto con te l'
hai controllato ok
succhialo via e prova a rispondere a questa simpatica
vecchietta probabilmente la mia faccia ricorda qui
quando ero bambina  solo per cavalcare in Italia
dall'Ucraina tutte le simpatiche vecchiette di
Spadina hanno fermato mia madre per
pizzicarmi le guance in un segno di benvenuto è
stato così difficile che Matrix è diventato rosso
bruciando nelle loro mani grandissime e callose
non appena si sono avvicinate a me io
chiudevo gli occhi ma non tiravo via
la faccia perché era una sorta di
iniziazione rituale vuoi davvero essere uno
di quelli del piccolo bambino lucido di
spadonnay ci sono quattro volte gli ucraini
più dei polacchi ma tutti gli immigrati bianchi
suppongono  sai quindi vuoi
davvero essere uno di quelli che riguardano la
spirulina ok dacci uno speciale
smalto ucraino che ha una guancia e le
nostre dita forti le trasporteranno
in originali e risparmiando una volta che smetteranno di
tirarmi le guance quando avrò dieci anni
avevano  mi pizzico le guance da sei lunghi
anni e solo quando la nota è che le mie
guance non erano reali è così diverso
dai vini italiani latinum
un pezzo principale non importa
akia party non c'è dubbio per me
sapevano che ero figlia di Nadia e
lì  sono quattro da 8 a 20 milioni di
persone della tua regione cranica che vivono
all'estero nel mondo il numero è abbastanza
traballante solo perché ci sono dei dubbi
su come considerare persone ad esempio
come i miei fratelli e tutti  a membri della
seconda e terza generazione otto o
venti minuti
lavora molti in Italia ci sono circa 240
stranieri della regione ucraina la quinta
comunità di freeboard più grande del
paese troppi o no lo vedo nella
spirulina abbiamo trentaquattro e
loro cinque sono  membri della mia
famiglia circa 100 stranieri eravamo troppo
pochi di noi nella mia scuola e l'unico
studente bene che non è nato in
Italia sono solo troppi o troppo pochi non
saremo mai il numero giusto qualcuno
pensa che noi  fanno parte della nostra
orda di acquisto qualcun altro che siamo eroi
non riesco proprio a decidermi probabilmente sono un
eroe barbaro ma conosco le storie
e la vita di tutti i giorni di alcuni di loro ad
esempio ogni mattina Yulia cammina per
tre chilometri camminando con
lei  tre bambini a scuola ecco perché
è sempre in ritardo al lavoro tutte le sere
Olga si annoia quindi non si stanca mai di
chiamare suo figlio in Ucraina e quando lui
non risponde si arrabbia chiama
amici e spettegola ogni  Domenica
Gallia va in chiesa che è così
ostinata con sua nuora che
probabilmente la povera ragazza lascerà le
zone di Dallas come la sua ex moglie che è
scappata da lei fortunatamente qui così la
vita quotidiana della gente comune quindi dove sono gli
eroi dove sono  i cappucci Burberry che
indosso Europa su una piccola bici
come Natalia percorrendo ogni giorno la
statale più insicura vicino a Napoli
di quella sfida con per la sua macchina o
il prossimo conquistatore sarà Tania
che è Victor Christ e spera che ogni
notte arrivi qui in Italia  per i
segni cementati i suoi trattamenti ok io sono
Anastacio meglio
anastasiya Alex e lui ora e mi sono trasferito
in Italia dall'Ucraina quando avevo quattro anni
e non sono un numero e non mi sento
invadere con Julia oh yeah
Galia Natalia Victor e Tanya noi  non sono
molti, sono cresciuto sentendomi un ucraino medio
o un italiano estraneo a me stesso e uno
straniero in questo e nel mio paese
prima di decidere di aprirmi al
mio orizzonte per questo concorso per la
f  primo concorso per il bene TEDx gioventù ho
preparato un discorso su una mucca sì su
una mucca un grosso grasso calmante mucca Freud non era
uno scherzo era un simbolo sacro nella mia
infanzia nel discorso ho detto che
mi piaceva esprimermi quando  disegnare anche
se non ho mai mostrato i miei disegni a
nessuno ma non ho detto che la
cosa più importante che mia madre quando l'ho incontrata
per la prima volta all'età di 4 anni
era quella che mi ha mostrato come fare una mucca
quindi la mucca era la  primo legame con mia madre
e ho avuto paura di perdere le
fosse da molto tempo, quindi ho sempre
tenuto i miei disegni lontani da chiunque ora
dove nel mio passato posso anche tutti i miei
ricordi e mi sono nascosto lì lontano nella
mia mente così  nel più lungo e non
diserto più dov'era ma qualche giorno
prima dei concorsi video
ho trovato una cartella quando avevo chiuso tutti i
miei schizzi e tenendo in mano uno di
questi fogli sbriciolati io semplici occhi veri
ecco tutti i miei sogni e le mie aspettative
erano state chiuse  in una cartella da anni
devo dire che il mio fi  il primo tiro è stato così
diretto e abbastanza contraddittorio, quindi ho
dovuto prepararne un altro Ero pieno
di pensieri senza parole quindi alla fine sono
andato da mia madre
mi sono seduto davanti ai capelli e ho chiesto per
favore mamma raccontami la mia storia e lei ha
detto davvero  voglio la nostra storia, lo
so e con parole forti e calme
mi ha spiegato il motivo per cui lei e papà hanno lasciato l'
Ucraina alla ricerca di una vita diversa in un
paese straniero ha anche detto che
vivendo in Ucraina e io quando ero solo
un raccolto volevano guadagnare abbastanza
soldi per comprare una lavatrice consiglio solo
phon e frigorifero tornate a
casa entrambi giovanissimi 22 anni
innamorati della forza di mio papà
e della gentilezza di mia mamma quando hanno
capito subito che Sparano era il posto giusto
forse il posto migliore  ci lascerà
persone e non solo come lavoratori ai miei
tempi mi sono rifatto con la lente d'ingrandimento e
vedere Vinnitsa mia madre mi ha anche detto che
dopo tre lunghissimi anni mio padre mi è venuto a
prendere e mi ha portato a casa in un
primo pomeriggio sul mio ch  l'infanzia una piccola
bambina che guardava verso di vedere sua madre in
tutti gli occhi marroni con speranza, paura e
molta Inga infantile fino ad allora
pensavo che mi avesse abbandonato
rifiutata per una nuova vita senza di me
ma parlando ora Franklyn ha toccato mia
madre mi ha preso in braccio e  mi ha portato di
nuovo a casa nella mia vera casa ho pianto
molto preparando il secondo discorso in tutti
questi anni ho frainteso mia madre
pensavo che fosse un tesoro beh
è stata una bella udienza che ha illuminato
tutta la mia vita quindi sono qui  oggi
vi racconto la mia vera storia una storia di una
figlia di una coppia di eroi e di una
parla inglese per essere
comprensibili a tutti qui in Italia
e poi in Ucraina parlando del
prezzo
e del potere delle parole quanto sono grandi gli
occhi  di un bambino che cerca sua
madre
quanto tempo passano le ore di una madre
senza sua figlia quanti bambini
quanti ragazzi grandi stanno cercando il modo
per raggiungere le ore delle loro madri
Sono stato fortunato molto fortunato Alan Kurdi
di ko  bani aveva solo tre anni quando aveva
chiuso per l'ultima volta i suoi grandi
occhi marroni cercando sua madre a San miglia
un Mar Mediterraneo annegato tra la
Turchia e la Grecia Ho fatto il mio viaggio di 20 ore in
autobus da Venere di Spiro Anna beh
non ha raggiunto  il sogno europeo che suo
padre è suo sta piangendo i suoi
sorrisi normali non più sogni non più
parole mia madre mi ha insegnato a fare una
mucca e quello è stato il momento più bello
della mia infanzia da allora ho tenuto gli
occhi sbarrati e ora capisco  che la
migrazione non è un momento ma un processo che i
migranti vogliono essere ascoltati piuttosto che guadagnare
noi tutti come esseri umani ha bisogno di
domande problematiche e personali
abbiamo bisogno di più vecchiette e cani a
bordo agenti della pattuglia di frontiera più storie e
meno passaporti grandi ragazzi chiudono
pizzicando gli ascolti  niente più ghiaccio vicino alle
lacrime sparate e inviate grazie per l'
attenzione